there's no time 13 o clock
so episode 93 yep so 93 the family
murders this is I don't really know much
about this case but Jenni's been
researching it for several weeks oh
you're gonna love this yes good this is
this is a rough one you guys told me I
said don't tell me anything about it I
want to hear about it
you know the night of the show yeah but
we're sitting back here and I've made it
sits on a Saturday night normally we go
out on a Saturday but we have to go out
on Sunday because we have a special
because it's Memorial Day weekend yes so
they're doing a Sunday night instead
though I've made Jenny and I a couple of
these fantastic things that we have here
in the United States I don't know maybe
if maybe you don't live in a country
that has access to two tequila a great
Mexican product you can have tequila
everywhere yes right I don't know man
you can't have it Saudi Arabia so we
don't know whose lips so I made a couple
of tequila sunrises and we've just
started on those man is this sunrises
are fantastic it's really it's the only
cocktail that I can tolerate tequila in
because I don't like it otherwise so if
you guys have anything that you want to
pour for yourself at your location go
ahead and get your pause the show and
make your favorite drink you might be a
mojito
although I D a beer it might be anything
although it won't be Saturday for them
cuz the show comes out on Tuesday they
can do it on Tuesday Tuesday afternoon
afternoon you can drink on Tuesday they
can drink whatever they wanted right
yeah true your your adults these are
fantastic though they are very good yeah
this is that Margaritaville tequila the
price of the head for Guerra Cuervo I
was gonna pay $35 for that well you got
a big face actually really good this is
really good and you can and you can
pretend you're Jimmy Buffett and yes you
can except you're wasting away in
tequila ville instead of margarita
doesn't quite work this I am beautiful
that taste if I guess it's guava I think
it is very nice nice so yeah totally
they did not pay us for this product no
we just we just bought it cuz it was
cheaper they didn't if you guys show go
get your tequila make a sunrise yeah so
what are we gonna do we're gonna do the
shout outs first we did a review our
last movie review was phantasm - yeah
that seemed pretty popular you
so if you haven't checked that out yet
go check that out yeah and also I wanted
to mention again our Zazzle store which
is it's a SOCOM / 13 o'clock and we have
shirts in a tote bag also I want to
mention our patreon page like I usually
do which is patreon.com/scishow teen
o'clock podcast and also we have a blog
13 o'clock podcast up WordPress comm and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you would like to make
a one-time donation I would also like to
say thank you to Michael who was one of
our patreon supporters and he recently
increased his support so thank you for
that Michael that was pretty awesome
yeah and yeah so I think other than that
like I said I usually mentioned my book
the faceless Villa and I'm still working
on I know I say this every week but I am
really working on the second volume it's
just taking longer than I thought yeah
it's gonna be a big book but it will be
yeah well I went through the other day
it was like doing word counts and stuff
like that and I was like okay well I
still have seven chapters to go and it's
already longer than the first volume I
think so I think it's gonna be at least
500 pages if not for I think the fans
will enjoy it and the audiobook will
probably be like 15 hours I know well I
found so much stuff it's like you know
what is in there if you found me there
down the rabbit hole of murders it's
like really it's kind of depressed I
haven't be an awesome the Robin holder
writers going down the rabbit hole
awesome book there's just more the more
you look and like I think you said that
before it's just like so many so many
more so many murders that's gonna be
another book I'm gonna put it all the
ones I forgot cuz I'm sure there's a
bunch I left out and there were some
that I had to leave out cuz there wasn't
like a lot of information about them and
so I think our next movie review I think
I'm gonna do Blacula yeah black Yulin
screen black of the screen yeah because
we got the scream Factory
yeah Rea that has both featured that's
right and if you guys want to get a head
start go ahead and get that now you can
get that on eBay both movies yeah
they're really there and they're in it's
scream fat scream factory blu-ray so men
the transfer quality is really good lots
of extras and those movies are some
straight-up good vampire movies they
influenced and rice and you
which when she wrote her Vampire
Chronicles so good movies I like them
and we're gonna get more into them when
the review comes up yeah so that'll
probably be our next one privately at
this yeah now that we've done that let
me do the news story and like I said
before we get into the family murders
and like I said I wanted to do the
family murders not only because someone
requested it but also because remember
back on I don't remember what episode it
was it wasn't I think it was episode 89
maybe where we did the Wanda Beach
murders and the disappearance of the
Beaumont children two very famous
unsolved mysteries from Australia and
this case is like tangentially related
to those two okay so I actually what
while I was researching those and they
were in my book I kept coming across
this one all right and so the more I
read about this I'm like oh man I gotta
do a whole show about this this is this
is [__] up okay so so that's what
we're gonna do but before we do that I
want to do the news story and we'll do a
true crime related news story now this
was something that normally I would do
like a golden state Killer update on a
true crime show there's not really
anything new with him he's not really
talking or doing anything like that
however I found this story in the Palm
Beach Post it's dated May 22nd and
evidently they they have used the exact
same reverse genealogical technique that
they used to catch D'Angelo yay they
have caught another murder suspect so an
old cold case using the exact same thing
and this was apparent this is in
Washington state and it was a double
murder from 1987 it was a girl named
Tonya van cauwenberghe I hope I'm
pronouncing that right she was 18 and it
was her and her boyfriend Jay Cooke who
was 20 and they were going to Seattle in
their van they were going to get some
furnace parts for I think it was her
dad's business or something so they were
going on a business trip and they
disappeared yeah and then a few days
later they found her body
she'd been raped and murdered and then I
think a day or two after that they found
his body - and he'd been beaten and
strangled or whatever they found him
wrapped up in a blanket and they didn't
know who did it all this time it
happened in 1987 well they decided that
they were going to use this genealogical
technique so they did the exact same
thing that they did in the D'Angelo case
in the Golden State killer case they
basically took the DNA from the old cold
case
files they uploaded a profile to an open
source genealogy website they identified
matches that were probably
great-grandparents right and then they
reverse engineered like back and luckily
for them they found this couple and this
couple had had one son and that was the
match right so then they did the same
thing they staked out this dude's house
they got a cup and a couple things that
he had thrown away that had his DNA on
it
and they picked him up and matched him
so they finally caught this person you
know allegedly you have been convicted
yet his name is William Earl tab Talbot
the second okay 55 year old man from
Seattle now they're only booking him and
I thought it was kind of strange they're
only booking him for one count of murder
for the girl's murder right
so I don't know if they didn't have
enough to pin the guy's murder on him
too cuz obviously he probably if he
killed the girl he probably killed her
boyfriend - I would imagine but you know
I I guess they're only gonna do what
they have solid evidence and yeah and I
think you know when we get into talk
about the family murders some similar
[__] happened there okay sometimes it's
it's frustrating because you're sitting
there thinking well obviously that's
must have been whodunit because of this
on the other thing but if you don't have
enough evidence then you know that it
can't yeah you know you can't get a
conviction what are you gonna do about
it
Jay and I were talking about this you
know I don't really believe that they
should be taking DNA from people at
birth I think it's unconstitutional
least under the u.s. American
Constitution but could you imagine the
business potential to where you could
ask let's say you start a company that
can get a contract from the government
and what you do is what your company
does is it puts out rewards
everybody gets gives their DNA to this
thing all right they give you $100 a pop
for your DNA and then they promise you a
$10,000 bounty if your DNA leads to an
arrest of an unsolved murder imagine
that I bet you I bet you you get a lot
of yeah Apple signing up for that and I
bet you you'd get a lot of unsolved
cases that's what I'm thinking like I
said I don't like I don't think they
should be able to like take your DNA or
use your DNA without you knowing about
it that's your brushing cuz that's your
DNA somebody wants to sell there by then
yeah if they say hey we'll give you X
amount of dollars if you willingly
your DNA and with the understanding that
it might be used to solve crimes crime
right enough I think that people would
probably do that I would do that yeah
well somebody said look you know we'll
pay you 500 bucks for your DNA and if it
or if it leads to an arrest
we'll give you $10,000 bonus like yeah
you know a lot of people yeah all right
I would do that sure would end up it
would make like a network a big crime
dragnet over the country to where you
could be able to pinpoint a lot of
offenders and also it might you know in
a little sidebar it might actually
discourage people from running crimes
because they're thinking oh [__] they're
like well even if you didn't give your
DNA you don't know if your relatives did
right right they could still they could
still get your ass might be like you
know I was gonna do this but you know I
don't know I better not be so my cousin
maybe some of my cousin's they've given
DNA and boy they tried me Yeah right yet
it might have a disincentivizing tricked
yeah so I don't know but like I said as
long as it as long as it's done
voluntary Allah voluntarily don't have a
problem but so evidently they've caught
this guy like I said it's allegedly he's
not convicted yet but they do think that
he was responsible for this double
murder from 1987 and so that's pretty
cool that they did that so I'm imagining
now that there now that that this
technique is been so it's got successful
that they're probably gonna use it to
solve a lot more of these cold cases
which means that's kind of Awesome
motion which means maybe if I write more
books later on them how can I have so
many to pick from cuz they'll have
actually solved them yeah I'll tell you
what uh what just tequila sunrises
kicking ass it is very good very nice
what oh you've already drunk half of it
hey I'm a man okay well I was talking so
I wouldn't drink I understand okay so
let's get into talking about the family
murders this happened in Australia in
the late 70s or early 80s I'm actually
kind of surprised I mean it's very well
known in Australia I'm kind of surprised
it's not better known in the United
States because seriously the stuff that
this person or people did to the victims
yeah this is really among the most
[__] up yeah it told me to prepare
myself
it's it's really it's messed up because
this involves kids yeah teenagers okay
so yeah it's it's pretty onions and
everything yeah all right yeah all right
then I'm ready I'm bracing myself
brace yourself people yeah hold on one
second is this can this be as bad as
that damn necrophilia episode you did I
don't it's a different kind of bad okay
all right cuz I walked out on Alan I
know
okay that's still actually one of my
favorite episodes we did just because
that was so this took place in Adelaide
which is in South Australia
now let's preamble this a little bit
because in 1972 there was kind of a big
thing now in Australia at the time
homosexuality was still illegal and
something that the cops at the time the
vice squad cops would do they were
supposed to go around like rounding up
gay people and stuff like that but
usually instead what they would do is
they would beat them up right it was
cheaper I guess okay so in 1972
evidently there were two or three
members of the vice squad and they
targeted these two gay men by the
Torrens River which was kind of you know
a gay meetup spot Roo they beat the [__]
out of both of them and threw them into
the river one of the men yeah when the
cops are after you right yeah one of the
men got out he had a broken leg the
other guy did not get out he drowned
yes Dan the guy who died was George
Duncan he was a doctor he was actually a
law lecturer right he had only just
moved to Australia like probably like a
month or two before yeah so he drowned
and there was such a public outcry about
this I mean I guess it had been going on
for a long time but people were kind of
turning a blind eye or whatever but now
these vice cops actually killed a dude
yeah there was an outcry yeah come on
so these cops have something better to
do who cares are these dudes are getting
off on that's what who cares I don't
understand why anyway I don't understand
why they're busy man right grown man can
do
he wants to do let him do it I don't
understand it no I don't either so
evidently there was such an outcry about
this that it actually led to South
Australia being the first state or the
first region of Australia to
decriminalize homosexuality because of
the the kind of furor that came from and
the in the wake of that snap them out
snap them out of it yeah you know it's
kind of like a dumb yeah this is like
some from the 1800s yeah now the
interesting thing too about this
particular case okay remember I said
George Duncan drowned the other guy
whose name was Roger James a passerby
helped him out of the water and drove
him to the hospital yeah this passerby
was a guy named Bevin Spencer von einem
okay Bevin Spencer Vaughn item will
become very important to this story
later Ohio [__] so it's just it's very
weird to me that he kind of you know in
1972 he helps this guy get on the water
and every time real villains oh yeah oh
yeah so let's go forward a couple of
things goes to show you that even a real
villain can sometimes do something good
yeah see everyone everyone's in a
morally gray yeah so homosexuality was
decriminalized in 1975 and then it was
kind of like you know some gay bars
opened up and or you know clubs that
were friendly to to gay people and stuff
so they're kind of became more more of
an open scene right here we are in 1979
and here's this guy named Alan Barnes
now sources vary some say he was 16 some
say he was 17 but you know he was about
that age so he still looked at his
parents his parents were English and he
kind of hung out I don't know if he was
gay specifically or if he just kind of
hung out because some of the clubs were
not straight up like there was a club
called the Mars bar in Adelaide that was
a gay club but there was some other ones
called like the Duke of York and stuff
that weren't you know just gay bars
there but there were people they were
like gay friendly so he hung out at a
lot of those places so joon-suk June
16th 1979 so Alan Barnes he's staying
over with his friend and they're hanging
out I mean they can't they kind of went
out clubbing and stuff like that now on
Sunday
they're gonna go hitchhike back to where
Allen lives and you know a lot of people
were hitchhiking it was the 70s so
they're hitchhiking there on this biz
main road in Adelaide they weren't
really having any luck and they're like
well maybe we should split up because
you know hitchhiker doesn't want to pick
up two guys you know because they're
gonna have to drop to go all over the
place and drop us off so they split up
now his friend evidently got home Allen
Barnes disappeared now Monday
his parents were kind of freaking out
and they're like we really need to call
the police so they call the cops
so as they're asking around they have a
bunch of witnesses come forward and said
oh yeah we saw that guy on I think it's
called Grand Junction Road is like the
main road there through Adelaide they
said yeah he was hitching a ride they
saw him getting into a white car which
was a Holden sedan and that there were
two or three other people in the car and
that was pretty much the last time he
was seen now a week later June 24th
there were some people hiking up in the
Adelaide foothills and at the bottom of
a bridge something called the South para
reservoir I think it's called
they saw something on the ground and
they said it looked like a body except
really contorted evidently someone had
tried to dump him off the bridge but I
guess they'd missed they wanted it to go
in the water but it just fell in the
dirt and I guess they didn't even notice
or something and then ride nice yeah so
they this is Alan barns obviously they
figure he's been dead for a couple of
days before he was dumped now it looks
as though he has been held captive and
that he has been tortured and beaten his
cause of death was blood loss from an
anal injury damn they think that whoever
killed him took something like a bottle
they're not really sure what it was like
a very large bottle or something and
just repeatedly put it in his anus until
he bled to death from the injuries but
yes so that's yeah so that's how he died
so you know while they're doing the
autopsy they also found some chloral
hydrate in his bloodstream along with
alcohol there was also a drug called
knock Tec which was a over-the-counter
like a sleep aid so they think that
probably someone had drugs
drink do they have any idea how long he
was held well he was found a week later
he was probably held about three or four
days damn oh wait it gets worse no good
not but you know with this that's bad
enough but like some of the later
victims there's no likey much longer
they also think that someone had washed
his body they never found the clothes
that he had been wearing what he
disappeared but when they found his body
he was wearing different clothes right
like someone else had dressed him and
the clothes were clean and everything
like that I would keep him somewhere
less a prisoner and they took yeah
original clothes more dressing him yeah
giving him stuff to wear yep no at first
no one thinks serial killer or anything
because this seems like a personal crime
I mean you know get somebody good news
like it's somebody that knew him so
pretty much the police are concentrating
on that so they're kind of interviewing
everybody he knows and friends and
things like that now two days after his
body was found someone calls the cops
anonymously and says look into a guy
named Bevan Spencer von einem he killed
Alan Barnes and the cops were kind of
like yeah okay we'll look into that when
we have time because at this point
there's a lot of guys well yeah and plus
they they're still thinking at some
point that this is someone that knows
him and they're pursuing that Avenue of
Investigation so the next victim that
turned up dead
was named Neil Muir and he was 25 now he
was more of a he had an apartment in the
middle of Adelaide but he was kind of a
little bit of a drifter he had been a
heroin addict and then he went to a
clinic and got on methadone and then he
got addicted to that then he stopped
taking methadone and apparently went
back on heroin now one of things I'm
noticing where these guys is you're
talking about him I'm looking at the
photograph something they all have long
blonde hair yeah although were the ones
that I'm seeing yeah just so what you're
saying really there didn't really seem
to be a particular physical type okay
not really okay it was just like whoever
or happened to cross their path really
but so you know the this guy he was like
I said he was a little bit older he's 25
he kind of looked like a little rock
star he had tattoos and long hair and
stuff yeah they look like guys that
maybe would be in the
banjee this priest or something like
that yeah KK downing coming at you yeah
now again they don't actually know if
Neil Muir was gay there were some rumors
that he was a prostitute but he might
have just been doing that for drug money
right they said he did hang out with gay
people and hung out at like the Duke of
York and there was another place called
the buck but those were not gay bars per
se they were just like gay friendly
establishments so it doesn't you know it
doesn't matter but I'm just saying that
they're you know they're not really sure
so evidently the last time that he was
seen alive
was August 27th 1979 and he actually got
kicked out of a bar because he was too
drunk and messed up on drugs and a
bouncer kicked him out of a bar and he
just kind of went staggering off down
the street and no one ever saw him again
yeah well not alive anyway it's not
setting the scene for me that he got a
like a sexual predator the guy oh yeah
he's going after younger guys who are
involved in drugs and in the club scene
and anybody and if you get too screwed
up or messed up around him he's gonna
get you that's what I'm seeing or based
on what I'm seeing so far well like I
said the first two victims were the rest
of him not so much now they actually
found his body the next day and it was
found by a couple of fishermen and it
was in the port adelaide river and they
were out fishing and they saw two
garbage bags evidently whoever dumped
them again they had you know they'd
wanted them to go in the river and go
out to sea or whatever but they kind of
missed so they were sort of just on the
shore now they open up the trash bags
and this is horrifying what they did to
this guy so basically he was cut up into
a bunch of different parts all of his
internal organs had been scooped out and
were gone
his legs and arms had been cut off and
crammed into his torso and his empty
torso his head had been cut off and then
whoever this was had taken a rope and
had put it through his mouth and through
the neck hole of the head and then tied
the head to the torso
and then he had like crammed all of it
into this bag okay well if he had also
they had also cut off all his tattoos
and like thrown them into this
they had cut his penis and they had cut
off one of his testicles and kept it
because they never found the other
testicle right sounds to me like they're
trying to make him more compact that too
but but the keeping of the testicle and
the cutting off of the tattoos that
seems like well sexual motive knives I
think cutting the tattoos off may have
been to try to hide his identity but
they know but then he they put the skin
with the tattoo in it okay and they kept
one of the testicles okay yeah now when
you when you shoot a deer in the field
if you're gonna transport it you usually
would do what you call field dressing
you remove the intestines if you do that
it lightens the body well yeah so if his
intestines were scooped I was probably
mostly having to do with lighting
lightening the body but like I said some
of this stuff seems probably trying to
make him small and compact
Braman into a smaller container to not
to attract attention which tells me
there may have been neighbors around
where he was killed
that's just what I'm thinking yeah cuz
if you if you don't have neighbors you
know worried about the size of the body
you can just sling him over your
shoulder and throw them in the back of a
trunk you know they're trying to yeah
keep this a low-profile I think I don't
know why they cut the tattoos off and
then just threw it back in the bag that
seems to defeat the purpose well yeah
that's what I mean I mean a lot of them
will knock the teeth out yeah take
finger tips off so you can't get any
fingerprints from him you know just
weird well like I said the fact that you
know his penis and testicles had been
mutilated and like I said you know they
they know at least one of the dudes that
did this he did get caught so this is
sexual section is what this is so this
is how this was done while I was alive
I'm not actually really sure they said
that he died the same way that Alan
Barnes had died by having something very
large inserted into his anus and which
caused him to bleed to death so he was
killed the same way damn so even with
that connection yeah the cops seemed to
focus more on Neal's drum problems and
they said well maybe he was in debt with
a drug dealer that had him killed
well you notice again 879 didn't they
know better back then I guess not but
like I said is obviously the hallmarks
of a sexual sadist yeah you don't do
that over drug debt right exactly so
that will they were kind of going
through all
his you know all his drug buddies all
his connections in that kind of way now
they didn't really get anywhere
they're obviously because that's not who
did it now interestingly after Neal Muir
was killed
the investigators actually finally
followed up on the anonymous tip to
interview Bevan Spencer on item they
went to his house and asked him about
Neal and he said that he did know Neal
and that he and Neal had in fact had a
sexual relationship four years
previously you know he said I saw him a
few days before the murder but he didn't
think he had and he didn't say he had
anything to do with it another thing too
that might have not put Bevin on the on
the radar was that they had this other
guy that they were looking at and this
guy was a dr. Peter Milhouse and he they
had kind of found him through Neal's
like friends and acquaintances and stuff
had kind of come back to this one guy so
Peter Milhouse they had a couple
different callers that called in and
said that Milhouse was probably the one
that had killed him or he was the one
that had supplied him drugs
so they think he was a gay man he was an
alcoholic he lived in North Adelaide and
he drove a white Holden sedan similar to
the one that Alan Barnes was seen
getting into and after Neil Muir was
murdered evidently dr. Milhouse kind of
went off on the he like went on a rager
like he was all like alcoholic and stuff
and finally he like hit rock bottom and
he had to go into rehab while he was in
rehab police started investigating him
and building a case against him and a
bunch of people at the local bars and
Adelaide said yeah we saw dr. Milhouse
with Neil Muir a bunch of times and they
seemed really close so now they're
thinking this guy is the killer
so he actually also when they searched
his house they found trash bags and rope
that were similar to what had been found
when they found a nails body so you know
it was all circumstantial yeah but it
seemed like he was kind of guilty so
they arrested dr. Milhouse and weirdly
even though they have many witnesses
have seen dr. Milhouse and Neil Muir
together on multiple occasions he says I
don't know that guy right but the thing
is they have the trial and he gets off
he gets acquitted kazusa there's not
enough evidence you know it's just it
was all circumstantial they they're
pretty much the only thing yeah they
found the trash bag yeah they found the
rope they're like in his house there was
kind of something on the bathroom floor
that might have been blood that had been
cleaned up with chemicals and stuff but
they couldn't pin anything on that's the
thing they're always looking for blood
and consciousness I've cut myself around
the house of Fort Bend my blood well
that's what I mean right
somebody was bleeding here what about
every time I was like thought out
hamburger and yeah some like hamburger
blood on the floor I mean you know what
do they do about stuff like you know I'm
not a big believer well that's not the
crime scene there's blood splatter all
of us yeah but roll well yeah that's
what I mean and that's probably why he
got acquitted because they were like you
know any did any the defense could argue
that could have come from anywhere like
somebody he might he just cut his hand
or somebody could have come up come over
and cut the round that's why you really
really need like solid evidence in this
kind of case they just didn't have it
you know and like I don't know if that
dude was involved or not I kind of
suspect maybe he was but they couldn't
pin it on him so he actually got off
after that a couple of years went by
before the next victim turned up and
this kind of took a different kind of
turn like other than the first two
victims so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna take a break right now
I could use a break you could of course
I could use a break another tequila
sunrise oh yes drink number one okay so
what so while you guys are listening to
commercials he's gonna go to campus and
you guys are welcome to make the drink
for yourself and and it's a Saturday
night for us yeah we work on Saturday
night we work all the time girls time
anyway yeah well I do entertaining you
people in writing books is a full-time
job for us yeah it really is
yeah it's more of a Janney though I sit
back I just do yeah you just gotta use
any credit for [__] yeah
well it's me and you cooking up a lot of
these plans to come up with these
products and you know
how what is the fan but what do they
want
yeah no one yeah you know communicating
with the people that buy your books and
listen to the show you know we love
these [__] we talk we love
these [__] we do yeah yeah of
course we do he's getting so hammered
already yeah how about their wish I got
zero I wish every one of you is over
here right now man we should do that one
time one of these days locals we're
gonna have like a live show we'll do a
live show we're all have something
drinking it we'll put it up that would
be fun wouldn't it would we have to I
mean I know we have some fans in Florida
yeah there Cleese talking the house I
don't care yeah we are yeah all right so
we're gonna take a break right now and
he's gonna go make another drink and
then we'll be back and talk more about
this horrible horrible case yeah okay
[Music]
okay and we are back and I am enjoying
the effects of tequila yep he got he got
a refresher for a French if I start not
making any sense it's okay yeah I'll
just I'll just look at you I'm gonna try
to make sense
okay good you're still making sense so
far okay good alright so the next victim
like I said this one is a little
different the first two you know older
guys kind of hung out in the club saying
stuff like that
this was a 14 year old boy oh [__] he's
going he's going that yeah mm-hmm all
right
his name is Peter Stagg Neff now this
happened on August 27th 1981 Peter
decides on that day he's gonna skip
school and go hang out with his friends
you know he's 14 yeah mess about how how
old I was in 91 or 81 about that yeah
yeah I was nine yeah but yeah so he
decides he's gonna skip school so he
pretends to go to school in the morning
and then at some point during the day he
comes back to the house and stashes his
backpack like he hides it in the garage
so he first goes to a place called Tea
Tree Plaza and hung out with some people
he knew there and then he was going to
walk up to this place called the rundle
mall and he was gonna meet his friend
Daniel and they were gonna hang out well
Peter never showed up so later on his
parents come home and after Daniel told
them hey we plan to skip school today
and then they found his backpack in the
garage and stuff and then you know he
never came home so then his parents are
like oh [__] he must have got abducted
so they call the police right now they
actually did not find him for a very
long time and in the meantime there was
another victim this other victim was
named Mark Langley he was 18 years old
now On February 27th this was 1982 he
was at his friend's 18th birthday party
his family
some of his family members were there
with him and stuff but they at some
point his family members left and he
stayed there so he could go hang out
with his friend Ian and Ian girlfriend
Paula so they're driving around in the
car evidently at some point they have a
stupid argument about whatever he gets
out of the car and starts walking and he
Ana Paula take off in the car but then
after a few minutes they're like oh well
we better go get him so they turn around
to go get him but he's gone
nine days later they find Mark Langley's
body in the Adelaide foothills he still
had on the clothes that he had been last
seen in other than the only thing I
think that was missing was maybe his
undershirt and he had like a like a
silver necklace
he said nine days yeah okay he had like
a silver necklace that had his horse Cup
sign on it his cause of death was the
same blood loss from an anal injury his
body had been washed his clothes had
been washed before he had been dumped
now the creepiest thing about this that
hadn't happened to the other victims
during the autopsy they found right
between his bellybutton and his groin
was a surgical scar like a new one yeah
now they think what happened was that
whoever did this they were you know
jamming things up his rectum dam and
something got stuck up in there and they
had to cut open his belly to get it out
because they were afraid that it had
their fingerprints on it
Wow they did it why he's alive yeah
because it had been cut and stitched
back up okay so that's what they're
thinking this had to be somebody with
medical knowledge right which they were
kind of thinking before just because
from the way that like Neil Muir's body
was cut up with a saw right you know
they were kind of thinking this is
somebody and now this is like a real
surgical procedure procedure that had
like the stitches it had stitches and
had surgical tape and everything yeah
and that's they think that I mean
they're not positive because they
weren't there but he was alive yeah but
they think that that's probably why that
was done because something got stuck up
in his intestinal tract and they had
meat in an outer why didn't he just wait
to the dude was dead and kill him and
then get it out when he after he was
dead I don't know he must have intended
to keep him for a while well yeah right
so yeah that was special mmm the thing
is though it's that he it seemed like
that he had been killed only a day or
two
after he was taken some of them they
kept longer but like it didn't really
seem like he because it he had been out
in the in the foothills that was done by
more than one guy well yeah yeah I'm
gonna get to that okay now as I said
before and this is another case where
there was chloral hydrate found in his
system there was alcohol in his
bloodstream that was four times the
legal limit you know and he was only an
18 year old kid
they also found a drug called Mandrax
which in probably in the United States
better known as quaaludes they actually
and this act would actually end up being
important because I'm not sure if the
drug was legal or if it was just kind of
over-the-counter at the time but because
in the 70s man Drax had become so
notorious for being a date rape drug
that eventually the government stepped
in and regulated it say said well you
can still prescribe it but we have to
have your name on records we want to
know who's got this [__] that's why
they're suspecting a doctor this is
somebody who can get this stuff with a
prescription or yeah or somebody that
takes it somebody that has a
prescription for it that's weird so
they're using drugs or drugging them up
to make them more compliant yeah well
yeah they're not they're not tied up
during the abuse probably they're
probably free but just really intact
I don't think they ever found like any
ligature marks or anything like that so
I'm assuming they probably just kept
them drugged up because some of the
victims had like four different drugs
and there's you know sleeping pills
quaaludes Amba fied right now a few
months after mark Langley was killed
they actually ended up finding Peter
Stagg Neffs body the 14 year old yeah
right now he had been left on this farm
and they found him because the farmer
was clearing his fields he was doing a
controlled burn right of his fields to
get the you know feels ready for spring
the the fire actually burned the body
okay so that's how they ended up finding
it so unfortunately they couldn't get a
lot of forensic evidence off of Peter
Stagg Neffs body because it had been
burned so they couldn't tell cause of
death they couldn't tell if he had the
drugs in his system or what have you
decided and then you know after this
misson for how long I think more than a
year okay yeah so all they could figure
out from his body was that and the
reason that he was linked to the other
victims was because it looked like the
same saw had been used to cut him up
because his body was cut into three
pieces
now the next one and the last one that
they know of the fifth victim his name
was Richard Kelvin and he was 15 years
old now he was actually kind of a higher
profile victim than the others because
his dad was Rob Kelvin who was a very
well-known newscaster Richard Kelvin is
at a park with his dad and his friend
Boris
they're kicking around a soccer ball
having a good time Rob Kelvin the dad he
goes home and then Richard walks Boris
to the bus stop and they're kind of
chatting at the bus stop Boris gets on
the bus and leaves at this point Richard
is only about some sources say 60 meters
some say 400 meters he was very very
close to his house but he never made it
there somebody got him in between so at
first the cops were like well maybe he
just took off he's a 15 year old kid
whatever but then a bunch of neighbors
came out and said no we heard like right
around 5:30 6:30 p.m. which is right
about when he would have been abducted
they're like we heard someone shouting
and screaming they're like we heard a
kid and we heard several voices
including a high-pitched voice that
might have been a woman's and they're
like and then we heard a really loud car
exhaust and like a car taking off and it
was kind of at this stage that because
of the witness testimony that we heard
several voices and someone you know
getting you know getting into a car and
stuff like that at this point they're
finally thinking this is a group of
people right abducting these I'm
thankful what I mean he's got more than
one of them at one time some of these
guys are eighteen year old kids in the
prime of their lives that's that's
warrior age those dudes can fight yeah
so you're talking about a middle-aged
guy probably doing this all right
because he has the financial means and
then medical skill yeah that's what I'm
thinking God be a group oh yeah and
these two is really what well and I
should know too that witnesses when the
first victim Alan Barnes
some witnesses reported seeing him
getting into a white Holden
dan that had two or three people in it
other than the driver right I was
talking about a sex cult that's what I'm
thinking that's pretty much what people
think this is right so they didn't find
Richard Calvin's body for two months he
was found by a family that were out
looking for rocks you know in the in
this forest and he was still wearing the
same clothes he had been wearing when he
disappeared he had also been wearing a
dog collar it was because and people
thought that was weird but they said no
because on those days well no no it was
just because him and his dad and his
friend were at the park and he's like
I'm gonna put on the dog collar like for
a joke so it wasn't punk rock no no he
was just doing it cuz he thought it was
funny we know I'll catch you who wear
dog collars at the club well yeah but
yeah it wasn't that he was just doing it
to be funny and it was weird because
when they found his body two months
later they had put the dog collar back
on him and he'd been gone for two months
now this is horrifying because they
think that he was kept captive for about
five weeks and they found all kind of
drugs in his system
right that manderach stuff knocked tech
keeping his ass zombified so he couldn't
escape yeah and he would go along with
whatever's going on yeah other than they
also found valium rohypnol yeah all kind
of stuff so at this point they're like
okay well all of these must be related
because pretty much all of these drugs
this is somebody with means to come up
with all these dreams now the
interesting thing is that they're like
okay well these drugs have been found in
the system of you know at least three of
the victims and manned racks
particularly was regulated because like
I said it was quaalude it had been musa
as a date-rape drug so they kept track
of everybody that was prescribed it
right so they painstakingly went through
the records of everyone that had been
prescribed Mandrax
it was usually prescribed as a sleeping
pill interestingly one name that popped
up was Bevan Spencer von einem so this
guy has to be involved and then later on
they had this guy well he was a kid
really so they've never given his real
name but he came forward and he told
police he said I was out walking he's
like I got picked
by this guy and this guy had a cooler
beer in the backseat and he's like he's
like come on I'm going to a party and
there's gonna be girls there and all of
a sudden he's like okay that sounds cool
so he gets in the car the guy gives him
beers the beers are laced with roofies
essentially he takes the kid to a house
where there are two women they're trans
women although they you know he doesn't
tell the kid that okay what ended up
happening to the kid was that he goes to
this house and then he starts feeling
really sleepy he falls asleep he wakes
up in the same house and he's been
anally raped damn so he reported it to
the police but he couldn't remember the
dude's name he kind of said what he
looked like but he couldn't he couldn't
remember where the house was he couldn't
really remember much about it because he
had been drugged most of time so this is
kind of all pointing to this Bevan
Spencer von einem person hmm so this
Bevan guy he's an accountant and he
still lives with his mom okay and he has
been prescribed several of the drugs
that were found in the kids systems for
sleep issues he had insomnia so he says
they start looking into him and they're
like okay well back when the first
victim was killed Alan Barnes
we had an anonymous caller that called
us and said hey Bevan Spencer one item
killed that guy right so they're like we
got to find that anonymous caller so
amazingly they are able to track down
this anonymous caller okay who first
tipped them off to this dude all right
and they I don't think they've ever
released his real name they just call
him mr. B huh messin with their legal
system yeah well now I think there was
actually a book written about this by
one of the detectives on the case it was
called Youngblood and the guy might be
named in there okay but I'm not sure
like every source I've seen online
because I haven't got to read that book
yet one of the main sources and you guys
should go listen to this after you're
done with this the unresolved podcast
yeah actually did a two-part show okay
this you were tumba that guy he's very
thorough he's like an expert on this
case yeah he loves this case and he had
actually read the book young so a lot he
got a lot of do so I got a lot of
details from his site
shoutout to him as well as you know I
went through Wikipedia and all that and
there's also a really good documentary
that was made by a crime channel in
Australia and it's called the butchered
boys and you can watch it on YouTube
because that's how I saw it
so that's also very a very good source
of information there's like interviews
with the families and investigators and
stuff okay but yeah so this mr. B person
yeah it's kind of weird because he keeps
saying that he helped Bevan drew and
they would drive around Bevin has this
cooler of beer in his back seat all the
time and they drive around looking for
young boys that they can entice into the
car with the beer or they say they're
going to a party there's all these girls
at this party come on we're gonna take
this party so apparently mr. B he kind
of almost sort of implicates himself in
like helping with the abductions but he
always says that oh well I wasn't there
like when he killed anybody or anything
like that but I figured that that's
probably what happened like I wasn't
there which I don't find right so now
they're like okay well this Bevan person
it's like not only does he have
prescriptions for all these drugs have
been found in this he's admitted to
knowing Neil Muir the second victim like
having a sexual relationship with him
and he had been seen with various other
victims at various other times so they
asked him about Richard Kelvin the fifth
victim the fifteen-year-old now he says
I don't know that kid I've never seen
him I was sick that week I called it you
know and all this OSHA
right that's him right there ya know
what a creeper yeah so then they ask him
they're like okay well can we search
your house and your cars and all that
and he says okay although he did have
two cars the cops are like can we search
both your vehicles he's like oh I don't
have that Ford Falcon anymore I sold it
to a family friend now he sold it to
this friend which apparently he did
because that friend came and testified
at the trial or whatever said yeah he
did sell it to me but the weird thing is
that before he sold the car to the
friend he painted the trunk yeah and
that's it now this is a Ford Falcon
right yeah you do realize that he's
probably talking about the Ford Falcon
xB that was mad Max's car oh yeah you're
right that was mad max's car if you
could get one of those in the united
states you're a wealthy man guys are
looking for that car to make a Mad Max
reproduction No
fantastic car van that was an Australian
Mustang really yes yeah cool car anyway
shout that shout out the Austrian car
Falcon xB so and then they're there like
he said other weird [__] like when they
were interviewing him like they would
ask him questions like would you ever
commit a murder
and he would say things like no because
it's unethical yeah seems like a weird
thing for innocent person to say you
know what I mean it just sounds very
strange so at this point they're like
okay well we think we have enough to at
least proceed with the investigation
against this guy's like he said weird
[__] we have this mr. B person like
saying he's been seen with all these
with all these people he has these
prescriptions so they go and they search
his house well they first they search
his car and they're like okay well
there's the cooler of beer in the
backseat just like mr. B said yeah and
then they go and search his house they
didn't find anything super weird
although he said he's like yeah I have
this one particular drug but I don't
have any man racks anymore I don't have
this than the other thing but when the
cops searched his house they found
valium man racks and knocked tech on a
little hidden ledge in his closet man
this is the dude like he was trying to
hide it
this is the dude Yeah right well yeah I
don't think no one's disputing that they
just don't know if he was the only one
right so they have enough to like
proceed and they're gonna go on with the
trials they're like while they're
waiting for the trial the cops go and
search his house again they just tear a
thing out and they're like okay now we
need to collect all this evidence from
this so they took carpet fibers they
took fibers from the bed they took
everything interestingly Richard Calvin
who was the fifth victim he had been
like I said he'd been kept for at least
five weeks right now on his clothing not
only did they find some Bevan spun
Spencer on items hair
they also found fibers from his carpet
and from his bedspread from his house
got him yeah so they're like okay well
that's definitive that prove you was
there so they told Bevan they're like
okay well we found all these follow this
fiber evidence and bam it's like oh did
I say I didn't know that kid here on the
night that he disappeared I was hanging
out with that I was hanging
with that kid yes like that kid came to
my house
[__] he's like I was consoling him
because he said that he was having
problems at school and he was having
problems because he thought he was
bisexual and stuff which is feelings
like no he wasn't he had a girlfriend
and everything it's like he was straight
alright let me tell you guys something
the best lies are like closest to the
truth if you're gonna lie lie real close
to the truth from the very beginning
you say oh yeah I knew all those kids
they were all gay you should see this
cake all those gay kids all the time
used to hang out with let me just go
over the house and then that probably
could I don't want to help these people
get away with [__] come on the thing is
though they're like even if that had
been the case right they're like look it
was two months between the time Richard
Calvin disappeared to the time that his
body was found right there like if he
had just come to your house and then
left and someone else killed him right
fibers would not still be on his clothes
rive weeks later they're like that just
it doesn't happen right so obviously he
was in his house obviously was yes now
like I said Bevins spot Spencer Vaughn
item they they could only get him for
that murder because that was the only
one that they had that fiber evidence
that was definitive like the rest of
them yeah he'd been seen with the other
victims yeah the drugs and everything
like that but there wasn't enough
physical solid evidence to pin the rest
of the [__] on it they did try to pin
two more murders on him yeah they were
gonna take it to trial but then the
judge ruled well you can't use the
similar murders thing from the richard
calvin case you can't use that in this
trial and they were like well [__] we're
[__] right so they decided to withdraw
the prosecution for the other two
murders so at this stage bevin spawn
spencer von einem has only been
convicted of the one murder but they
gave him life because they're pretty
sure he had something to do with the
other ones too however the question is
not if he was involved because he
totally was right with at least those
five if not more but how many other
people were involved the reason they
call this the family murders is because
they think that Bevan
item was only one of this sort of loose
cabal yeah sort of powerful people in
South Australia that were basically
raping boys they were drugging and
raping boys and sometimes killing that
wouldn't doubt wouldn't doubt it because
remember how in that other case where
you had basically priests Catholic
priests in a Catholic school pimping the
girls out to the cops and local
politicians yeah
whenever somebody has access to young
kids they seem to be able to get
powerful pervs yeah called in on it yeah
I bet you they use that as dirt I'm
talking about to control and manipulate
one another like a mafia it does seem
like that almost kind of like you know
like in the Jemez but in the new James
Bond series like Spectre they used their
crimes to manipulate one another because
they all got dirt on each other wouldn't
surprise me because and another thing
they said too was that Bevin fine item
yeah was not the sharpest tool in the
shed yeah look at that dude yeah he was
kind of a doofus yeah and they're like
they're kind of they don't think he was
smart enough right to have pulled all
these off all by himself and like you
said he was kind of an older like a soft
he was an accountant he would you've got
his ass kicked if he was by himself sure
buy some of these 18 year old coz some
of these 18 year old kids were like two
big athletic kids you know so there must
have been other people involved and you
know not only the thing with Richard
Kelvin and people hearing multiple
voices when he was being abducted but
also in Alan Barnes's case were more
than one person was seen in the car so
they think that there were several other
people involved in some of these other
people there's one guy who has only
noticed mister our he was a business
owner and they think that maybe he was
involved he was kind of known as he had
a business that was two stories and then
on the second story there was this room
that was marked private and all that was
in there was a mattress on the floor and
no one was really allowed to go in there
and they said now he was well known
around town for like every lunch hour he
would go cruise around the bars like
looking for boys and [__] like that so
he didn't really there's a weird [__]
going on right well I mean right now
second-in-command of the Vatican is
honored you know he's being tried he's
being tried for trafficking over
thousand boys I mean it's like the
Vatican it's like the pedophile command
base now yeah what the [__] and we all
knew that that [__] was going on even in
the Catholic Church but at that higher
level the second in command a right
underneath the Pope how long is that
[__] then going on I bet you think we're
on for a long time yeah okay get back to
this story all right so you got mister
are now mister are also had a roommate
who was a doctor and his name was Steven
woods and he actually ended up going to
prison in 2011 for sexual assault boys
stuff that he didn't 81-82 those so they
think that he might have been involved
too there was a another guy that they
think was in the group early on was this
guy named Aaron Stephenson now he was a
lawyer now he got murdered by his
teenage lover in 1979 but he was
probably part of the loose cabal also
there was a connection between all these
guys they knew each other
they drew they ran in the same sir
exactly what are the chant of course
they were doing this [__] yeah it's like
even if it wasn't like I don't think
they have like [__] meetings or
anything like that but they for sure ran
in the same circles a quick yeah they
hung out in the same places it was a
scene they were a bunch of older guys
with money yeah that wanted to prey on
young boys dirty [__] and yeah and
that's what they did they would go and
they would fly these boys with alcohol
they would drug them they would rape
them sometimes they would kill them yeah
that sounds plausible yeah now the
problem is that mr. B who like I said I
don't know if he's ever been identified
I couldn't find his name but apparently
he was named in the book they are not
really sure like a lot of the
information came from him and they think
that he was super involved also because
he seemed to know a lot about what Bevan
was doing even though he always says oh
well I wasn't there when anyone got
killed I but he for sure was there for
some of the abductions and the rapes and
stuff the weird thing is that he also
they're they're not real sure how
seriously to take like some of his stuff
some of the stuff he said checked out
but then he also said that Bevan Spencer
von einem
was the guy that had kidnapped the
Beaumont children which we did a show
about oh yeah and also that he was the
one who encamped Joanne Ratcliffe and
Kirsty Gordon from the Adelaide Oval in
1973 look these dudes all knew one
another and they all had dirt on one
another I guarantee you when they killed
somebody
they told one another too yeah you know
they did like even if they work is
all-aware for every single thing all new
because they all had leverage over each
other I couldn't tell right I knew so
yeah so like I said they they started
calling this the family it's kind of
like a loose cult but as I said Woodards
he got done for sexual assault so he's
in prison
Bevan Spencer von einem is in prison
other ones not so much and honestly the
first guy that they put on trial
Milhouse for Neil Muir's murder yeah I
kind of he got acquitted but I kind of
feel like he might have been involved
too right and they just couldn't try him
again for that I'm not saying he's dead
now he died and uh he died a couple
years ago in a nursing home but I kind
of feel like he might have been involved
as well but yeah Bevan was put in prison
in 1984 but I know it's kind of like
people are like oh it's a conspiracy
theory and stuff like that but in this
case I think it's legit I mean all of
these dudes knew each other yeah they
knew and the creepy thing is that some
sources say that there are as many as 12
guys that are suspected of being in on
this ring and if Bevan was responsible
for those five and if he was responsible
for killing the Beaumont children and
the two girls that got kidnapped from
the Adelaide Oval which maybe he was
maybe he wasn't mr. B said he was and
some of his other [__] checked out then
that would be ten people for him but
like how many people did the other dudes
kill these little these little cliques
these are what cults they go out and
rape and murder people are not as rare
as people think no they're probably does
these little things are appearing in the
news today so I kind of feel like this
might be the case where are we where the
it's just a bunch of you know they're
doctors lawyers yeah that's the
magistrates that's the weird thing
they're almost there like men of power
there was like a TV presenter because no
one would suspect them and they have the
power in them in the might well that's
another thing right detection well I
think having money is kind of important
because they can I guess it's easier for
them to like hide their activities yeah
because I think I miss and I don't
remember if mr. B said this earth there
was another source that said this that
Bevan had like rented an apartment brah
first the specific purpose of making the
victims that's like natural selection
the guys that don't have any brains or
money or position in society get caught
real early yeah the ones that do can do
it for a long time and they can recruit
others of their kind so then they become
like a mafia pedophile which is what
this sounds like right yeah and so the
case was actually reopened in 2008 and
they've been trying to link some of the
other suspects with DNA at the moment
other than Bevan who was already in
prison they're looking at three suspects
specifically suspect number one this is
mr. our suspect two is Steven woods and
there was another suspect also that's
mr. B who as I said has never been named
those are the three main suspects that
think they think that there might be a
bunch more though actually this has gone
way way way over its okay everybody's
enjoying the time and everybody's made a
drink and they're along with us I mean
you know I'm on my second tequila
sunrise jenny has even finished her
first that's because I'm talking Rockets
too much to talking too much I'm talking
too much to drink I'll tell you what
though tequila has a very unique effect
on the human metabolism my face feels
red it is red it is red yeah that's not
well it does make you like warm like my
face is writing it warm I really have
only drunk like half of one very nice
very nice if I guys have never tried
tequila sunrise it's Tom and Jenny
approved here the ice yeah but yeah
another thing that I wanted to mention
and this turnip I'm imagining that this
comes from the book called Youngblood
which is about this case the website of
the unresolved podcast he mentions it as
well in 2014 there was this guy named
Trevor Peters and he had passed
and he was very into the gay scene at
the time like in the late 70s early 80s
and his family were going through his
things and they found a diary and in the
diary he was talking about all of these
people he was talking about Bevan von
meinem he was talking about Alan Barnes
he said in the diary that Bevan Spencer
von einem had spoken to his hairdresser
about kidnapping Allen Barnes yeah and
he also named a bunch of other suspects
in the ring yeah and before this you
know to our listeners out there this
what we're talking about here this is
not the gay scene we have gay friends
some of them in the gay bondage scene
they are not like this this is not
[__] normal no these are just [__]
up yeah you can't really like gay people
are not like this the straight people
aren't like that straight people don't
go out with my last little girls this is
just a weird [__] that happens there's a
ring of murderers really yeah it's like
I didn't really want yeah I didn't want
anybody the impression that it's like it
you know what I mean this isn't normal
this is a normal behavior for anybody if
our friend Toby found out about some
[__] like this he would [__] kill you
well yeah kill those dudes yeah well and
honestly I think the same thing applied
at the time because in the gay scene at
the time it was you were looked at as
scans if you went after like wilty yeah
boys and say that people thought that
was weird yeah creepy and gross yeah so
it's like even at the time they were
weird I was like you know we got gay
fans so you know we got gay fans gave
listeners and just to our straight
listeners who may be young and don't
really understand what the gay scene is
about it is nothing like that I mean you
wanna have a good time you go to [__]
gay bar me and Jenny go to gay bar plan
oh yeah yeah this was just a messed up
these are a bunch of messed up old guys
with money yeah who just got off on
having power yeah variable teenage boys
yeah and like I said most of it didn't
but they just it was it was basically
just crimes of opportunity yeah look at
that little fourteen-year-old kid he was
just walking in the mall to visit his
friend and they get kin snatched him you
can have gangs of old straight guys
doing the same thing well they did girls
they got that also it has nothing to do
with your orientation it's just these
are [__] murderers yeah these are
just crazy-ass people and like I said I
think it would be good if at some point
like I said they're investigating more
people now since the case has been
reopened and they have DNA from the time
so they're trying to link more people to
it but as of this recording Bevan
Spencer von einem is the only one that's
in prison and he's only in prison for
one of the murders right even though
they're pretty sure he did the other
four but they are still classified as
unsolved just because they didn't have
enough to pin it on him and like I said
there were a bunch of other dudes that
they think might have been involved too
but I don't need to go in all that this
is already long enough but you know so
this is kind of rambling but this was
like a huge case and there's so many
different events I didn't even mention
like the Truro murders which took place
like shortly before women our show
really is based around introducing these
cases to our subscribers we tend to be
as complete as we possibly can but some
of these some of these cases are so huge
man you could get off in two months yeah
and the information on but I think this
is a good introduction to this case yeah
and like I said if you really want a lot
more in-depth detail about this case
unresolved podcast he did a two-parter
it was it's almost two hours long about
this case and he just cut and also he
did like a huge write-up of it on the
blog which is unresolved
Emme slashed the family murders you know
he wrote out the whole script like on
his blog so you read it or he can listen
to it and there's also a really good
documentary called the butcher boys yeah
it's an australian crime show and it's
about 48 minutes long and it's like a
documentary about the case - so that's
on youtube if you want to go check that
out but yeah this is like it's a it's a
fascinating case and I got interested in
it like I said when I was researching
the Beaumont children disappearance
which we did a show about a few episodes
ago and someone and someone subsequently
requested that I do it and it seems like
a lot of its lesser-known in the United
States I feel like even though it's
[__] up and crazy but no but yeah so
we'll and now because yeah we're just
going on a long time and we're getting
to a point where it's like let's go
drink it
then watch horror move in the bed and
watch horror movies we did the same
thing last night and here's a funny
thing tom says to me this born and he's
like cuz I got pretty hammered last
night yeah you also weekend's you know
it's Friday night I don't really drink
during the week away yeah holiday season
yeah Friday and Saturday night I'm gonna
drink yeah but so he says to me this
morning he wakes up and says you know
there's something to be said for just
sitting in bed drinking yeah okay well
at one point like I got I was I was
watching Mystery Science Theater and I
was so drunk that I just said [__] I
just fell asleep yeah she blamed me I
just got really really sleepy and said
oh my god looks like I should just lay
down but you're like yeah it's kind of
nice because you can just you be a
really drunk in the drive home right
yeah you don't have to go anywhere
you're just already in bed you're asleep
yep you just put your head down and fall
asleep it was really nice
baby cookie jumping up witnessing this
what is wrong with these people why are
they sleeping yeah her cat she woke me
up at 6:30 this morning and that kid
well I can't be mad at her as she's too
cute she's more monkeys she is very
monkey like she's more monkey than cat
like she likes she climbed up I was
laying on my side and she climbed up on
my side and like flopped yeah over my
side and then started doing that little
making biscuits thing get my claws with
her claws like on the other side of the
blanket right or making biscuits
yeah that's oh she's doing she's sucking
all right so that'll do it for episode
93 hope you enjoyed this super-sized
true-crime episode and remember if you
like true-crime check out my book the
faceless villian villain that protects a
billion billion billion okay check out
my book that faceless villain how you
buy you one is out in volume two will be
out this summer I promise
also be sure to check out our latest
movie review which is phantasm - and
check out our dazzling screen back of
the screen will be coming soon yeah that
should be out on Friday yeah check out
our dazzling watch 13 o'clock we have
shirts alright
we have shirts and a tote bag and also
check out our patreon page at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast or
go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast wordpress.com and there's a link
in the sidebar to a PayPal account if
you'd like to make a one-time donation
and I think that's all of the shout outs
isn't it I think so okay this is we'll
see you guys next time then bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]